i want my baby back baby back baby
baby
no one not myself no one at chili's
heard the piece of music after it was
done and thought this is going to be
around for 20 years i thought it'd be
gone after six weeks
yeah if you want you can have one yeah
you know i haven't eaten one now why
start now
my name is guy bommerito i'm an
advertising creative director and
copywriter and the one responsible for
the chili's baby back ribs jingle bell
sauce most everybody's grown up with
jingles and i guess the older you are
the more jingles you remember because it
used to be you know the heart and soul
of the entire industry
and so by the 90s when this song was
written jingles had gotten to a point
where they were the lowest common
denominator form of advertising and
everybody avoided them because they were
they were typically annoying and
unpleasant we did it because the client
insisted on it we never would have done
it otherwise i was so embarrassed to
take the assignment back to my creative
department that i just wrote it myself
i want my baby back ribs people to
either say that that's my favorite song
i love it or they would say if i hear
that song one more time i'm going to
stick a fork in my eye when the song
first started taking off my biggest
concern was i hope that's not the only
thing in my obituary i hope that i do
something else you know that that
surpasses that because i really don't
want to be known as the guy that did the
baby back rib song